fielding great candidates everywhere you
see the energy out there Democratic
turnout in the primaries in 2018 has
been up 84 percent from 2014 the
president has a 90 percent approval
rating among Republicans remember in the
midterms
it's the party that's turning out their
base we have to turn out our base first
in two months we have a chance to
restore some sanity in our politics if
we don't step up things can get worse
President Obama made a speech now if
that doesn't get you out to vote for the
midterms nothing will well the countdown
is on were under 60 days here and we're
getting closer to the midterms as you
look at the generic congressional ballot
as it stands now the RealClearPolitics
average has Democrats up almost eight
points we have Power Rankings on the
foxnews.com website on the house side
you can see likely Orlean Democratic 202
likely or lean Republican 203 those
yellow ones in the middle 30 toss-up
that is what will determine how the
house is determined who's controlling
the majority and the Senate side you
have 19 likely Democrat for lean
Democrat 5 toss-up tune lead lean
Republican 5 likely Republican and there
you see the breakdown you go state by
state and some of these states are
getting tighter that they're not
supposed to get tighter
according to Republicans on the Senate
side let's bring in our panel steve
hilton is former adviser to british
prime minister david cameron host of the
next revolution here on fox news channel
maher lies the national political
correspondent of National Public Radio
and Washington Post columnist mark
teason all right mara let's start on the
Senate side will you look at some of
these numbers that is the surprised look
republicans were supposed this was
supposed to be a pickup opportunity year
for them there are about five is still
very good the map is great for them
there are five Democratic incumbents
running in red states some of which
Trump won by more than double digits and
last week we saw a bunch of polls
Missouri Tennessee Indiana where they're
dead heats the Democrats are holding
their own for now I mean these are very
red states but this is not looking the
way that Republicans have thought it
would look early
in the cycle alright so the president's
approval rating according to some polls
is now dipping under forty percent but
the economic change since he took office
the numbers if you just look strictly
down the line the real GDP growth the
unemployment rate consumer confidence
average hourly earnings all heading in a
very positive direction economically
does one outweigh the other when it
comes to some of these swing races well
when you have the kind of economic news
that we have I mean you've got 700,000
people who've moved from part-time to
full-time work three million new people
working who have full-time jobs under
President Trump
you've got manufacturing jobs growing
here wherever he was said he was gonna
fight for the Forgotten Americans in the
manufacturing sector fastest growth in
14 years layoffs half century low
fastest wage growth in nine years
we Trump should be cruising to a huge
victory in these elections but he's not
how why is that well look at what we've
been talking about in the news for the
last couple of weeks I mean the whole
fight about John McCain and the flag
going up and down the the Woodward book
the anonymous op eds
the all these different things and a lot
of them are self-inflicted wounds
there's chaos in the White House and
it's overshadowing the the real
accomplishments that the president is
having he that people are doing better
under Donald Trump across the board
black unemployment african-american
unemployment unemployment is down and
yet these races are so tight it's it's
it's being caused by this reaction to
the chaos in the White House the White
House bringing out a senior economic
advisor today to make that very case if
you look at the the collected body of
evidence the notion that what we're
seeing right now is just a continuation
of recent trends it's not super
defensible President Trump
deregulated the economy we've talked
about how that affects growth the tax
cuts have had exactly the predicted
effect on the economy that's brought
businesses back to the US factories back
to the US and created jobs for ordinary
Americans it's clear the data that
there's been a trend break Kevin haslums
not on the stop every day
you know but they're making the case
yeah it's a good case they should make
it but I think the important point for
the Republicans to remember is that
people don't vote out of gratitude the
economic stuff that might have an effect
when people are feeling it I think it's
particularly effective for swing voters
not so much the base but the real point
I think that they need to grasp is that
elections are generally about the future
and that is particular those swing
voters if you're gonna get them out and
get them motivated it's not enough just
to tout the achievements you've got to
actually say if you don't get the
Republicans back then all this is at
risk the Democrats will put up your
taxes confidence will go down the job
prospects will get worse you've got to
have a bit of that negative push hey
anger and fear and I'll tell you
something what Donald Trump has done is
he has made the election about him it
doesn't really matter what anybody else
says he is so dominant that it matters
what he says and he has another version
of that message which is that the
Democrats win they're going to impeach
me and remove me from office I think
those would get the base but you're
certainly not and here is by the way
Maxine Waters over the weekend who
whether your depends on where you sit in
the Democratic Party whether she helps
your dad hurt you I wake up in the
middle of the night and all I can think
about is I'm gonna get him I'm not gonna
move and as you know there's a
difference and how some of our
leadership talked about how we should
handle all of this they say Maxine
please don't say impeachment anymore and
when they say that I say impeachment
impeachment
so that definitely plays for her Trump
wants to play that over and over and
over again I mean you could see every
but again you know the the reality is is
that what Donald Trump has failed to do
with he's probably the most successful
president of my lifetime in terms of
getting his agenda through getting the
economy moving judges everything down
the line and how can he sit president so
successful be so unpopular it's it's
incredibly frustrating because a man
like him he's he has a core base of
about 43 44 % that'll be with him no
matter what they're gonna go out and
vote and this in these midterm elections
he should be at 50 51 52 he should be
getting people coming over based on the
day based on the data and how in the
affects of his policies and for some
reason he hasn't been unable to expand
what you do in an election is you get
you to energize your base and you try
and broaden your appeal as president
that he just cares about the base that's
all he seems to care about he doesn't
want to expand he just wants to
intensify what he's already got